توجهنا الى المناطق الشماليه الغربيه من
مقاطعه دانيتك المناطق الساخنه جدا نحن
الان على اطراف مدينه مارينكا وهنا في هذا
الاتجاه تدور معارك طاحنه ما بين الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني وتعتبر هذه المدينه
قريبه جدا من مدينه باخمط التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الاوكراني ويطوقها الجيش
الروسي من جوانب ثلاثه الناحيه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه والشماليه بعد السيطره على
سوليدار
دخلت قوات وفاكنر من جنوب مدينه باخمت
وبعد وصول المقاتلين الى العمق الاوكراني
من اطراف بلده ايفانكا جنوب المدينه تشهد
المنطقه قتال شوارع بين الطرفين في ذات
الوقت الذي اعلنت فيه كيف انسحابه جيشها
رسميا من مدينه سوليدار المعارك الاعنف
على الطابق الثاني من هذا الموقع هذا هو
مصنع قديم للحليب هذا هو حال المصنع اصبح
ثكن عسكريه كبيره للقوات الروسيه امام
محوره مدينه اوغلودار جنوب المقاطعه فيطوق
الجيش الروسي المدينه بنفس استراتيجيه
التطويق مدينه
ويستمر بقصف مراكز الجيش الاوكراني داخل
المدينه مع محاوله اقتحامها من الناحيه
الجنوبيه بعد ان سيطر على طريق السريع
الذي يوصل الامدادات من مدينه باكروكا
شمال غربي
اثبت الفرقه الخاصه في الجيش الروسي لنغطي
عمليه اقتحام اواخر مدينه مارينكا اما
محور روماريكا فما زال يشهدوا معارك
واشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه اضافه الى
القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين مع سيطره
القوات الروسيه على مواقع جديده في الثلث
الاخير من المدينه على الخط الاول من
المواجهه مع الجيش الاوكراني في ذاك الطرف
نرى البنايات المدمره من المدفعيه
والدبابات والقذف وحتى
الاشتباكات بالرشاشات هذه هي المعارك وهذه
هي مدينه ماريكا في مقاطعه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر